back to las vegas now today we are
celebrating bagel fest day and who
better to do it with than seagulls bagel
mania they have been serving our
community for over 33 years and here
with us we have assistant general
manager who goes by uncle g uncle g how
are you i'm doing great how you doing
good it smells amazing in here and
obviously you guys are known for your
freshness your bagels your sandwiches a
little bit of everything but really
quickly just give us a little history on
bagel mania
33 years we're making original bagels uh
you know and a bagel add a bagel unless
it's boiled you got to boil the bagel
for it to be original okay that's where
you get the shine and the crust and you
know it's got to be crispy on the
outside
and chewy on the inside that's that's a
true bagel well it smells like a true
bagel in here and you're going to put me
to work in a second we have our gloves
on but really quickly i want to talk
about some of these sandwiches that the
professionals have already made tell us
what's on the menu well on the menu we
have a list of breakfast sandwiches and
lunches we do a lot of
authentic jewish proprietors but you
know but the main thing these are all
some of our common ones this is our foxy
loxy which we have i love the name
it's a smoked salmon sandwich
oh my gosh is that what we're gonna make
here in a second i'm gonna make here in
a second that's the good one we'll see
if i was trying to have a little healthy
choice here it's called the summerlin
girl we used
palinka what's on that one it's avocado
we got a little feta cheese tomato
hash brown cake and egg whites wow i
love a good avocado toast and that
reminds me here is your basic uh you
know this is your basic old school just
a
sausage egg cheese it comes with bacon
or ham can't go wrong with that one
right yeah it looks amazing this is one
of our newest sandwiches
we call this the bris the mazel tov the
muggle top i love it it's a brisket with
barbecue cheddar hash brown i mean
absolutely delicious i'm cleaning that
one when we're done here that looks
amazing you'll probably only do about
half of that probably it'll be all over
my face but it'll be worth it we also do
like i said we do a lot of cream cheeses
we have about 13 cream cheese that we
make in-house all in store made we
brought with us today a garlic and herb
a chive a plain and an apple cinnamon
wow okay uncle g put me to work what are
we making we're going to make a foxy
loxy feet okay let's do it let's start
this out here let's go here okay first
you're going to smear let's get that on
the real thing the real thing you're
trusting me with the real real thing
we're going to do top and bottom okay
and we're down there is it a lot is that
what we're going for here let's switch
sides here you can do whatever you want
yeah you can go there that's fine is
that good yep okay
she says right okay i'm part jewish my
husband's family is jewish
i know how to make a good bagel
and then sam is a good one for you yeah
we're loading it up okay we got the
cream cheese okay then we're gonna just
so you know we sprinkle the little bit
of capers on the bottom the cream cheese
holds it in place and that's really what
you want then yes and add some some
flavor there all right gonna get that
down there so then you're gonna go ahead
these are all set up here so just take
that salmon okay a whole piece you can
use your glove you can use the tongs
come on let's go i'm trying to look like
a chef but you know we're just packing
it on there all right that's all right
all right we're putting the salmon on
and everything at bagel mania it's
always fresh always ready to go right
yep is that good do any more okay sliced
tomato okay
slice onion sliced onion putting it on
there put your lid on
put the lid on we're making leon what is
this the fox foxy crandall's foxy locks
it's one of my popular sandwiches you
know i love it shows how to cut it
professionally i'm moving back over here
so we're in the shot then we're going to
cut it in half right in half looks
amazing
oh my gosh
and you can have that and then you can
end with some apple cinnamon was that
what that other schmear was this is
apple cider vinegar julia made a
delicious delicious boxing how'd i do
unbelievable am i hired you're hired you
guys are right up the street from us so
i'm coming over yes yes uncle d thank
you so much this was so much fun and i'm
gonna eat all these carbs for days carbs
don't count when you're on tv right
thanks for being here mercedes i'll send
it over to you